what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay uh so getting into or getting back
into too powerful for Marvel movies and
this will recovering hyper storm well at
least one version of hyper storm there's
two versions of hyper storm there is
David Richards and then there's Jonathan
Richards Jonathan Richards is the one
that's most well known but I think David
is the one that's the most powerful so
David Richards comes out of it's like
Earth 2600 or something like that and
it's basically where operation
zero-tolerance never ended so wine the
clock back tonight like 1995-96 rightly
mom was like okay so we're gonna do the
onslaught saga because we're basically
gonna do a soft reboot and we're going
to reboot the Fantastic Four and the
Avengers because nothing is selling but
the X minutes fight a man but with the
onslaught saga coming to an end what
this did is this initiated operation
zero tolerance and the reason why was
because with the aftermath of onslaught
and the threat that he posed humanity
was kind of the kind of like restarted
humanity's hatred for mutant kind right
because they were like okay so onslaught
was basically the amalgamation of like
Magneto and Examiners Minds merged into
one and then I tried to destroy
everything and so we're not okay with
mutants anymore and so because that like
it was it was trying to recapture like
the Chris Claremont era of like mutant
hatred so like God loves man kills and
you know project-wide away can only kind
of stuff which it kind of worked but
what ended up happening here is Marvel
basically created a character named bash
and really it was it was Mark Mark Waid
and Andy Kubert
I think they created care to call
bashing now Bastion was a character who
was like years in the making right so
like you go back to uncanny x-men 141
and 142 and you get Days of Future past
and then we had data future present and
what days of future present revealed is
that in the future of the Days of Future
past timeline the Sentinels were gonna
create Nimrod who was like this perfect
Sentinel that could like basically adapt
to the powers of others and all kinds of
crazy stuff so Nimrod ended up in the
present day now in addition to Nimrod
what you also had in the present day
there was really a byproduct of like
Stephen Stephen Lang Sentinel program
and a handful of other things was master
mold and master mold was basically like
this giant signal making machine what
ended up happening is Nimrod merged with
master mold and when that happened it
created Bastion now coming out of that
Basham's goal was to eliminate mutant
kind and so after the events of the
onslaught saga abashed and it sat down
and said okay so what we want to do here
is we want to implement a plan called
operation zero tolerance that was
basically spearheaded by Bastion but was
supported politically by Senator Robert
Kelly and this came out of the
assassination of Graydon Creed which was
basically like this guy who was just an
ta like star
the anti-mutant so and so forth the
result was that after the assassination
of Graydon Creed which seemed to have
been done by a mutant
this gave Bastian all the approval he
needed from Senator Robert Kelley to
initiate zero tolerance and zero
tolerance was bashing creating like
these these prime signals like these
uber sentinels basically and that led
into really like in a tip by Bastian to
capture a bunch of the x-man and and for
the most part he almost succeeded and it
was it was kind of crazy ultimately he
was defeated they ended up forcing him
through the siege perilous which was
this device that was given to the x-men
by Romo the guardian of the the
omniverse more or less and those who
passed through it get their lives
started over again right so like during
fall of mutants for those guys who have
heard that story that was an event where
the the x-men actually passed through
the siege perilous
and then everybody believed they were
dead and they kind of got a chance to
start their lives over it was weird
anyway the idea behind this was that
following the defeat of Bastion
operation zero tolerance was officially
defeated and so on and so forth in the
alternate reality earth 2600 Bastion
never lost and so the events of
operations your tolerance reached their
totality when the prime signals
basically conquer the world
and so in this alternate reality
Franklin Richards and I think Rachel
summers had a son named David and David
was crazy powerful but we didn't
originally know instead what we did is
we picked up with the exiles and the
exiles were basically a group that
existed back in like the the mid to late
1990s in the early 2000s and they were
essentially like an alternate universe
hopping team right so it's like the
multiversal avengers except just not as
cool and so the idea behind this is that
they would travel from like reality to
reality and they would like face off
against these different threats that
were given to them by the Tallis kind of
like this entity that would essentially
tell them like hey are bad things
happening there you should go stop it
and like that's what they would do that
was basis behind their story anyway
they're basically tasked with travelling
to that's alternate reality where the
signals that conquered everything and
picking up like David along with a
handful of others and like rescuing them
well shortly after this happens the
exiles are told like you have to kill
David and and they're not sure why let
their not in the uninsured why but then
they're basically told that in this
future David will essentially conquer
reality and the reason why is because of
the power David possesses so as the son
of Franklin Richards David has all of
Franklin Richards reality altering
powers right so it means like he's
basically equal to Galactus in power the
guy is virtually godlike for the power
that he has not only that he can
actually manifest and use the powers of
the Phoenix force without actually
possessing the Phoenix force itself
right so like he can just become the
Phoenix like
no we're but the coolest this is
probably the coolest display of power
David has a coolest power david has
david has the ability to copy the powers
of anyone he's aware of who has powers
right so like he can be aware that
wolverine has a healing factor and then
duplicate Wolverines healing factor but
he can be aware of like cables tella
telepathy and telekinesis and then just
duplicate that not only that he can
actually push their powers to a higher
level than they ever could and so it's
so it's nuts he doesn't actually have to
copy their power he's I have to like
take their powers but he didn't just be
aware that they have them and then use
them and so it's just like wow so like
no wonder that guy would basically
become God so it's like it like it's
like a Swiss Army knife you guys like a
one-man army but but to me that's what
makes David so cool now one of the
things to bear in mind is because of the
because of those three aspects of his
power he possesses he basically can do
anything he wants to he can alter
reality I mean he can give himself any
superhuman power he wants to but he can
also duplicate the powers of others and
he can use the power of the Phoenix
force which is the sum total of all life
that has ever currently desert will ever
exist in like the multiverse
so the godlike is insane now that kind
of begs the question what would happen
if David Richards Fonzie on face off
against like the Liddy tribe you know I
mean I don't know I don't see I don't
think he's like protege let's see it
seems like he is his protege can copy
the powers of anybody he sees but if
David is aware of the power of the
Living Tribunal that he can duplicate it
but as far as I'm aware it's limited to
the mutant population you can't really
do anything beyond mutants anyway that
was a vision that they basically got
sitting like you had to kill Dave and of
course the story transpired but you take
a character like that and you throw them
into the MCU and it becomes cool because
the funny thing about this is that if
David's power is limited to mutant kind
then there goes his ability to duplicate
the powers of anybody because mutants do
not exist in the model Cinematic
Universe yet now if they roll them in or
when they roll them in it depends on how
they do it if they go with the ultimate
universe origin then basically those say
Nick Fury was the original super soldier
Nick Fury escaped after Nick Fury came
Steve Rogers
but between Nick Fury and Steve Rogers
Canada kidnapped James Howlett they
basically wanted to make him a super
soldier then discovered a mutant gene
they sent the sizin into a chemical they
spread it across the earth and then
suddenly mutant gene started waking up
all over the place hits we got mutants
like the Marvel Cinematic Universe may
take that approach or they may take
something a lot more complex and say
mutants have always been here and we
just didn't know about them or something
along those lines I don't really know
how you inject mutants into the MCU this
late by basically saying like
everybody's like they've been here the
whole time and nobody knew I mean my
theory on Charles Xavier hiding their
existence is a good one the question is
how do you
how do you basically make the case like
mutants have to come out now honestly
for the most part I don't care what they
do they could say mutants showed up
because like the genie from Aladdin
showed up and he was like hey
so like mutants and like and like that's
it like I would I wouldn't care like you
could be the Disney genie like looking
all beautiful and blue and just up here
in like mutant kind is here now but I'd
be okay with that I wouldn't I would not
have a problem with that
that would be a be awesome the Adonis
some some bald guy like some some
middle-aged bald professor who's like
never succeeded in his life is like you
know hey genie I wish I had telepathic
powers and I wish there were other
people like me and the genies like done
mutant population I'd be okay with that
anyway so the mean population doesn't
exist there goes that part of of David's
powers but that still leaves him with
the reality-warping powers of Franklin
and it still leaves him with the ability
to manifest the Phoenix force the issue
here is that that's a potential future
version of David so we don't know if
that version would actually come to
fruition the version that we saw the
Exile spent the most time with was a kid
so it was like Hope Summers before Hope
Summers we don't really know like if
that's what he was going to become it
was just a fear that he would and so if
we did get that version of him well then
yeah he would crush the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I mean like nobody would really
be able to stand against and the only
people that I could think they could
stand against that version of David
because being equal to Galactus is not
the same as being all-powerful David's
not like the molecule man Owen Reese or
like the beyonders or even protege or
like any like any of those guys who have
insane reality warping powers right he's
not on that level you'd be dealing with
a character who was essentially on par
with Galactus and Galactus has been been
defeated on several occasions like he
was defeated in a solo seer in the the
Thanos solo series by Thanos he's died
on more than one occasion or just been
defeated on more than one occasion so
somebody with like the Infinity Gauntlet
could probably beat David now it depends
like the Infinity Gauntlet with the in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe for all
intents and purposes does not appear
like appear to be like the Infinity
Gauntlet in the comics but the
difference here is we've only ever seen
Thanos use it to snap half a life in the
universe out of existence and then we've
seen the individual Infinity stones use
on their own but we haven't really seen
fans to do anything with the Infinity
Gauntlet outside of destroying half the
life universe so we don't really know
the full power of it in the MCU if the
Infinity Gauntlet in the calm in the
movies really is on par with the comics
they're like that's your key to
defeating defeating David you know that
you would need a power of that scale
either that or Doctor Strange goes to
like the Dark Dimension and just
unleashes Dormammu who onto the main
onto the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
then Dormammu it like full-strength
could probably take out David um but
again like he's he's not unstoppable
right Lee he's not totally unbeatable
he's a character with some caveats and
even then like there's no guarantee he
would know how to use his powers
completely I mean the future vision of
himself indicated he did but again like
along the way we don't know exactly how
all that stuff would manifest but I'm
kind of curious let me know the guys
thing down to the comment section if you
are new here to comments explained make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]